tournon table parce que ce que vous avez
vu vous avez cette histoire le journal
le times a révélé que neymar aurait
imposé au paris saint germain une
augmentation pour reste un club alors il
aurait demandé de toucher 1,13 million
d'euros par semaine au lieu des 750
milles qu'il touche en ce moment il est
à ce qu'on peut arrêter l'émission
maintenant tu peux pas donner une
augmentation à tout le monde donc je
vais augmenter une personne ou à une
seule personne qui peut alors julien
donc on va pas se passer comme dans koh
lanta d'abord vous allez me dire
pourquoi pourquoi vous mériteriez d'être
augmentée et ensuite chacun va botter il
y aura l'urne ici que découvrirez tout à
l'heure awek remis celui qui aura le
plus de votes sera augmentée ouais c'est
évidemment alors que c'est tout le monde
vote pour toi les invite également votre
on l'a dit semoun et qu'elle il vous
faites partie de ceux qui peuvent être
nombreux bien sûr comme quoi on peut ne
rien faire être augmenté
on adore alors oui mais tout simplement
parce que je suis le premier sur le pont
pour préparer l'émission vers 9 heures
du matin avec avec marc et simon 2 99%
des scoops de l'émission sont apportés
par mois oui non mais dire truc sérieux
quand même 2 et 3 surtout j'en ai besoin
je n'ai pas droit de fanni la vidéo est
pas pareil moi dès 9 heures du matin
tchèque marine au téléphone ensuite
quand le et j'envoie les et je lis des
livres je les livre des invités
ah oui enfin vrais arguments voilà
jamais avec des invités ou c'était voilà
simon spectacle c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai et vous écoutez les le boys and the
death album de badge ou et 20 mo bob
marley connaît pas bonjour monsieur le
maire bien ont prévu que j'adore et li
jun évidemment pas là après je veux dire
que voilà c'est pas pour me vanter mais
j'ai jamais une info donc ça veut dire
que jamais démentie donc c'est pas à
cause de moi qui ai les polémiques sur
l'émission
[Rires]
jamais des hurlements comme on peut les
faire gilles jamais paix comme comme
benjamin donc ça vaut un bon voisin de
table je pense j'ai aucune copine
donc j'ai pas de mariage en attente ni
de deux femmes à caser comme
chroniqueuse donc c'est plutôt un
avantage
j'ai jamais une proposition d'une autre
chaîne ni aucune ambition personnelle
donc je suis d'une fidélité à toute
épreuve donc toute façon je les preuves
ah oui ça c'est le français c'est pas
dans mes qualités allez maxime galy
alors déjà je suis moins cher et de loin
donc si vous augmentez moins cher que
les autres
2 je vais à toutes les conférences de
presse son rapport d information et je
m'endors pas pendant les projections
[Musique]
je ne dépend d'aucun groupe média donc
je dis les choses de la manière la plus
objective qui toi c'est sûr
multicasquettes magicien dj donc je sais
à peu près ses serres je suis celui qui
travaille le plus puisque j'ai pas de
neuf donc j'ai que ça à faire
[Applaudissements]
déjà je trouve que le ton attitude est
moche c'est dégueulasse c'est diviser
pour mieux régner parce qu'ils vont se
détester sa valise on est une famille
mine de rien on peut pas se déguster
mais c'est vrai on n'y arrive pas on
peut essayer non mais non je voterai
pour la seule femme de la table dazhou
toi tu es qui pour l'instant je dirais
merci à ce que sous la table il fait que
des trucs de ouf parce que vous vous
rendez compte que je gagne moins que le
roi des fumistes jean-michel à ce que
moi je ne fais pas de cinéma je fais pas
théâtre produit pas de documentaire
parce que je me cache pas comme certains
ici pour donner mon opinion je tairai
leur nom par charité c'est isabelle et
maxime
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que l'émission c'est tout pour moi
parce que c'est ma vie parce que parce
que j'en ai envie parce que j'en ai
envie
voilà parce que il en est besoin aussi
et surtout amusez-vous
et puis derrière j'appelle tout le monde
à fatou sarr d après vous faites ça avec
le public
moi je suis public de cyril hanouna je
veux rester ouverts vous resterez
d'accord ok on n'est pas payé isabelle
et ben moi j'ai pas de gros besoins
j'aime pas cuisiner j'aime pas
l'électroménager
j'aime pas le raisonnement de rien les
sextoys j'aime pas les vêtements de
marque j'aime pas non mais j'ai pas de
permis de conduire dont on aurait pas de
ramasser le nez pour randonner pas en
avoir et d'ong et de plus en plus grande
pour sa femme ont augmenté moi j'ai rien
compris mais bon bernard montiel
alors moi il faut pas augmenter parce
que j'ai déjà les uv ça coûte cher
c'est ce qu'est ce qui n'est pas son
point soleil fusil par mois non j'ai une
carte d'abonnement alors parce que je
fais des lises un public d'abord ça fait
32 ans que je fais de la télé et ce qu
avait 5 ans quand ils m'ont vu la vidéo
gag ils ont maintenant 20 ans ils sont
heureux je l'espère de me revoir ici
dans le cas de cette émission est qu à
ses gènes dire non et donc ça leur fait
plaisir j'espère de me revoir ici après
tant d'années ont fidélisé un public les
gens besoin d'identité comme ça physique
sa récusation est surtout à la sympathie
pour moi en tout cas moi je suis heureux
d'être là et que le public soit la
housse et les gens savent qui tu n'aides
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous méritez une augmentation alors sa
vie ce jeu vous devez vraiment augmenter
dakwar ne suis jamais drôle je déteste
me déguiser je suis complètement bidon
en happening je vous fatigue avec des
livres en permanence donc rails pour ça
merci augmenté mois un discours de miss
france tu sais et je veux que moi alors
moi ça fait sept ans que je des rushes
tous les offres de ses missions car est
donc maintenant je connais très très
bien tous les rouages je sais qu'il ya
une seule chose qui marche si si c'est
le chantage j'ai vraiment des bosses il
faut qu un monde que je n'ai jamais
montré même sur moi évidemment son
abandon en quarts récemment je veux tous
vous faire tomber donc vaudra mieux
maintenant augmenter mais vite
[Rires]
plusieurs lui confère déjà un petit
cadeau c'est qu'il ya votre nouvelle
émission qui démarrera le 28 mars
prochain
treize mesures assez vite et on a des
images exclusives à vous montrez vous on
va regarder des images j'ai appris qu'il
est jeune il a été payé pour cette
émission il appellera une augmentation
assez normalement cessé pour saluer le
travail au noir
il ya beaucoup de gens ici
[Applaudissements]
c'était bien lui comme ils en sont c'est
nicolas sa sardine ce qu'elle légumes
ressemble plus à stéphane bern
il a une tête à ça tu es comment un
prénom américain mais pour un français
qui fait quoi dans la vie
d'ailleurs dans les yeux vous faisiez un
sketch je me rallie d'explosion foule
[Applaudissements]
et on oublie l'augmentation pourquoi on
vous augmenterez alors moi il faut
augmenter cyril dessel qui arrive le
plus tôt dans l'émission je suis la
première à arriver tous les jours mais
pour faire quoi
j'étais explique jean luc tu là pour
l'adar ko s'éclate on chante on danse
j'essaye d'être de bonne humeur tous les
jours et jack vous c'est vrai je vous
aime et on s'éclate voilà oui c'est vrai
mais je pense que pour sa bad girl
melanie photos de tous ces jeunes
seraient tout proche et comme max j'ai
le plus petit salaire donc ce serait
cool ça dépassera pas les autres et elle
arrive si tôt si c'est parce que quand
on arrive c'est le sosie de j'y viens d
après ya beaucoup de travail alors les
chéris nous aller voter chacun votre
tour vous voter pour la personne qui
mérite une augmentation et je vais
dépouillé ici on peut pas voter pour soi
mais d'aller me remettre et ne pouvaient
pas voter profond que ça allait venir m
on sent vos papiers ici je vous dirais
qu'ils méritent une augmentation